round 2 of the sink filled cup here in  st. Louis it was a day of bad mistakes  as the world's best players started to  feel the tension grandchester co-leader  Hikaru Nakamura seemed to blow the win  against anish giri but the young  Dutchman overlooked a brilliant  defensive move and ended up losing the  game bringing Nakamura back into  contention max in vashi lagrave got a  powerful opening position against  five-time world champion Viswanathan  Anand but a horrible oversight by the  new world number two caused his position  to crash and burn leaving the veteran  anon tied for first defending champion  levon aronian got nothing out of the  opening against his old rival Peter  Svidler but the seven-time Russian  champion made some crucial mistakes in  time pressure leaving aronian in a  familiar place atop the leaderboard the  world's top players look to raise their  games to the next level round three of  the same field cup starts right now